ah
[Música]
aquí comienza es jazz hoy el programa
feminista de france 24 las mujeres y las
niñas son las principales víctimas de
las formas de esclavitud moderna y trata
de personas esta edición no nos lleva a
colombia porque en el norte del país
zona con presencia persistente de bandas
criminales la explotación sexual de
niñas es un fenómeno creciente y sin
atención del estado están siendo
captadas entre los 12 y los 13 años a
través de amenazas a la vida y a la
seguridad de sus familias entre ellas
hay pequeñas migrantes cuya estadía en
el país es condicionada a la explotación
todo esto sin intervención efectiva de
las autoridades que por el contrario en
muchos casos se convierten en cómplices
para france24 no fue posible entrevistar
a quienes viven de primera mano estas
violaciones atroces a sus derechos
humanos pues hablar pone en riesgo sus
vidas pero una invitada muy especial nos
acompaña para ampliar esta denuncia que
ella ella misma publicó en forma de
artículo escrito en la revista cambio en
colombia ella es de la periodista maria
fitzgerald maría bienvenida de ella soy
una anguila muchas gracias por la
invitación no gracias a usted por su
tiempo maría y empezamos hablando un
poco de cuál es el contexto que se
desarrolla alrededor de la zona del
catatumbo de esta parte norte del país
tan cercana a venezuela
el catatumbo es una zona que eeuu
históricamente por el conflicto armado
en el país es una zona que se ha
convertido en refugio tanto de
guerrillas como de grupos paramilitares
y que adicionalmente por lo porosa que
es la frontera ha empezado a tener una
presencia también de presa de grupos
armados transnacionales como lo es el
tren de aragua por ejemplo todo esto
crea una especie de desgobierno en la
zona que además se ha terminado de
agudizar por la falta de relaciones
entre venezuela y colombia a nivel
gubernamental y eso termina causando que
las personas queden sometidas
básicamente a la voluntad de los grupos
armados y pues esto deja claramente en
un nivel de vulnerabilidad muy alto
principalmente a mujeres y niñas de los
dos lados de la frontera sin embargo lo
que nos hemos encontrado es que en
colombia hay una presencia muy fuerte de
trata de explotación sexual de menores
venezolanas principalmente por su
estatus migratorio dentro del país y por
supuesto los tratantes abusan ante este
desgobierno que usted menciona mariah
pues aparecen las lideresas a denunciar
los casos
a estas niñas ya sus familias qué ha
pasado con ellas en el caso muy puntual
del catatumbo nosotros tuvimos acceso a
hablar con una lideresa
que es quien debería estar hoy acá pero
no puede porque está amenazada por
múltiples personajes y actores armados
incluyendo actores legales ella ha
denunciado la presencia de redes de
explotación sexual que son dirigidas
incluso por miembros del ejército y de
la policía y eso la mantiene a ella en
un riesgo constante eso se ha convertido
en una realidad común a la región
nosotros pudimos irnos hasta el
catatumbo pero si ésta cúcuta en donde
también hablamos con otras líderes de la
zona que se han encargado de trabajar
temas de trata de explotación sexual de
mujeres y son personas que tienen que
mantenerse básicamente invisibles cuyas
denuncias tienen que hacerse casi que
entre susurros porque todo el tiempo de
por medio hasta que ellos puedan
sobrevivir y no solamente está en
peligro la vida y la seguridad de las
mujeres que asumen este rol de lideresas
que pasa según el artículo que ustedes
escriben cuando una madre o una familia
intenta denunciar para proteger a sus
hijas pues de que caigan en estos
crímenes
eso suele ser muy complejo sobre todo
por la forma en la que están funcionando
las instituciones deberían dar atención
a este tipo de situaciones nosotros
hemos venido haciendo un paneo a nivel
país de lo que ha venido ocurriendo con
la trata de explotación sexual de
menores
tanto en cartagena como en medellín en
catatumbo a campo gota en cúcuta
distintas regiones y en todos los casos
nos encontramos con una formación
punitiva por parte de las instituciones
y también una inoperancia absoluta
entonces el icbf que debería encargarse
sobretodo de restituir los derechos
cuando hay una menor involucrada lo que
hace es ir y quitarle la niña a la
familia y ponerle penalidades a la
familia cuando en realidad lo que se
debería hacer es un proceso muy distinto
lo mismo ocurre con la fiscalía que nos
recibe los casos lo mismo ocurre con el
ministerio de interior que no toma en
cuenta las realidades de los migrantes y
esto se ha convertido en un factor que
facilita muchísimo que las redes
continúan explotando a niños niñas y
adolescentes en el país
bueno y viendo ese panorama que existe
en su opinión maría y en lo que ha
podido investigar dentro del medio
cambio qué opinión se hace usted de las
rutas en colombia para proteger a las
víctimas de formas de trata y de formas
de esclavitud moderna son inexistentes
son inexistentes de muchas medidas y
empecemos por por arrojar uno de los de
los resultados que tuvimos haciendo el
reportaje del catatumbo allí contamos la
forma en la que nosotros intentamos
hablar con el ministerio de interior
para preguntar sobre la situación de las
mujeres migrantes en el país y ellos
tenían un subregistro tan impresionante
que perdón si no recuerdo el número
exacto pero decían algo así como que en
todo el país se viene encontrado 127
casos únicamente no vas nada más cuando
solamente en el catatumbo en este año la
asociación con la que hablamos ya tenía
77 casos más o menos entre ellos 24
menores de edad y esto se replica en
otras partes del país que es lo más
grave por supuestos y sobre todo en
otras regiones en las que el volumen es
un poco más alto
regiones como medellín el eje el eje
cafetero cartagena todas estas zonas que
se han convertido en espacios donde el
turismo sexual se ha convertido en una
realidad donde ofrecen a las niñas niños
y adolescentes por catálogos que se
venden por internet
en esas regiones también se replica toda
esta realidad sin embargo parte de lo
que nosotros encontramos es que en el
catatumbo puede que las proporciones
sean muy similares a lo que encontramos
en otras ciudades pero es una realidad
absolutamente silenciada en medellín
cartagena al menos hay una que otra
persona que habla sobre el tema pero en
el catatumbo está totalmente
invisibilizado y además de eso mariah
porque el panorama empeora y empeora
cada vez que vamos ahondando más en este
tema en 2021 la defensoría del pueblo
emitió una alerta hablando de esta
posibilidad y de este riesgo de
explotación sexual en menores de edad
desde entonces algo ha cambiado más aún
si nos vamos más hacia atrás y pensamos
en el 2017 ustedes lo registran
organizaciones no gubernamentales ellas
habían hecho alertas estamos hablando
2017 2018 19 20 21 22 y todavía no pasa
nada no pasa nada y por lo contrario
parece agudizarse incluso más nosotros
nos hemos venido encontrando con una
serie es decir a mí me da risa a ver en
twitter por ejemplo los comentarios de
la gente que hice pero eso siempre ha
pasado
efectivamente siempre ha pasado la
explotación sexual de niños niñas y
menores de edad y lamentablemente eso es
una realidad constante en nuestro país
sin embargo lo que ha venido pasando en
los últimos cinco años que además se vio
agudizado por la pandemia es que muchas
más familias muchos más niños niñas y
adolescentes tuvieron que volcarse a
este tipo de situaciones para lograr
sobrevivir no y sobre todo maría que
ella en un plano más de ética y moral
pues puede que suceda desde toda la
historia de la humanidad pero el real
problema aquí es la normalización del
tema y la imposibilidad o la
ineficiencia del estado para entrar y
tomar acciones en estas zonas que además
están tomadas por grupos armados y
grupos transnacionales ustedes lo
denuncian precisamente si hace un
momento que me ha preguntado por la
defensoría muy puntualmente
creo yo que ha sido muy evidente que
sobre todo la última administración de
la defensoría fue totalmente inoperante
con muchas de las denuncias que se
presentaron en todo el país
de primera mano de casos de defensores
regionales que emiten muchísimas alertas
para que lleguen a la defensoría general
y no son tomadas en cuenta sus alertas
son totalmente ignoradas eso es algo que
se ha replicado muchas de las regiones
que yo he visitado siendo reportería y
es siempre defensores en la región
diciendo acá nos están haciendo esto y
estoy esto y una defensoría general una
fiscal y una contraloría total y
absolutamente inoperantes y mientras
tanto la humanidad de mujeres y niñas
completamente destruida y anulada y en
el peor de los casos pues fallecimientos
de los que me imaginaría que no hay
mayores registros tampoco eso es otra
realidad es una cosa muy difícil eso fue
la última nota que hicimos respecto a lo
que implica para muchas mujeres cruzar
la frontera bien sea por las trochas o
por el puente
hay muchos casos sobre todo de mujeres
muy jóvenes de entre 13 y 16 años es
decir también podrían ser calificadas
como niñas yo las pondría como niñas que
van a cruzar la frontera por las trochas
y simplemente son desaparecidas y
absolutamente nadie se pregunta qué está
pasando por ellos nada más en este año
el observatorio de género de norte de
santander señaló que creían tenían
indicios de que había aproximadamente 74
casos de mujeres que han cruzado la
frontera y no se sabía absolutamente
nada de ellas y esto se configura por
otro accionar de los grupos armados pero
también hay una denuncia que no hemos
terminado de publicar pero te lo hago
contar y es que el ejército también está
involucrado en lado y lado con la
desaparición de estas mujeres entonces
es una realidad que al final termina
teniendo muchos
actores que son los que están haciendo
la explotación pero justamente son
tantos que termina borrando se por
completo la identidad del victimario y
entonces quedan estas mujeres sometidas
a una serie de inoperancia es totalmente
desamparadas por todo lado sin que nadie
diga mucho
qué se sabe de esta participación de la
fuerza pública en los crímenes de
violencias sexuales de trata de mujeres
de esclavitud moderna contra niñas y
contra adolescentes son usuales y esto
también te lo digo por hablar
directamente con las víctimas
nuevamente en el viaje cúcuta pude
hablar con varias mujeres que habían
sido sometidas a sus redes de trata o
que voluntariamente han ejercido la
prostitución sin embargo quien las
explotaba en esa en ese ejercicio de la
prostitución eran personas pues que no
les permitían tener los réditos para que
ellas tuvieran bienestar a través de esa
labor sin embargo parte de lo que ellas
me decían y me contaban reiteradamente
era que tanto la policía como el
ejército solía ir a las zonas donde ya
se estaban para
robarles dinero pedirles coimas o
simplemente decirles usted tiene que
acostarse conmigo si no me la llevo para
la frontera y le dejo ya votada eso
cuando no las atacan físicamente cuando
no las electrocuten con los pacers
cuando hacen bueno una serie de
situaciones y también por los días en
los que estuve ya estaba corriendo una
noticia en la que ven encontrado al
menos a tres uniformados de la policía
siendo los que dirigían
de explotación sexual de menores pues me
haría sobre esto hay mucho que hablar y
yo solamente podría recomendar que
nuestros televidentes siguieran los
reportajes que ustedes están haciendo
continuamente contándonos un mapeo sobre
la situación real de la trata de la
explotación sexual en colombia muchas
gracias a ustedes porque además este es
el primer paso si es un tema invisible
pues hay que hablarlo hay que contarlo y
estaremos atentos muchas gracias
nuevamente por la invitación y ojalá que
esto es un esfuerzo que podamos hacer
para mostrar mucho más esto y una
responsabilidad gracias maría y a
nuestros televidentes de gracias una vez
más por estar con nosotros sigan en
france24 y nos vemos próximamente en
ellas hoy
[Música]